[Music]
[Applause]
you're too afraid holy cow you're not
going to see the art the arts always
going to be to you because we
can't show it to you safely it's a
simple thing go
no one's punching the face
[Applause]
[Music]
second one he goes he loses his get the
hip the hip now takes energy over the
foot
so he loses grip whoa loses its grip and
he doesn't have the momentum so you take
the leg and the head turn so the reason
he doesn't have the momentum Suzuki's
grip on it
there's not pulling down as much so
you're over here right arm the head in
the left the head and wherever you are
you find those things
[Music]
[Applause]
watch his body as it's traversing across
the mat you see I keeps moving keeps
moving keeps moving
that's not the art that's just
so it's not about speed it's about
completing a cycle of action and having
it be the next one do you understand so
if I shorten one side roll action you'll
stop this was supposed to in here if I
do it in a way that I have to now start
a new cycle of action kills
okay should not stop they should be
continuing from once
do you understand job they get speed now
let's go there isn't any here see I keep
this Center mine till I take the flag
[Music]
there keep your selfish copy
once I get this you can see that this
hip is open to his so as he's coming
around me this leg here
[Music]
is in front of his hip
so I timing this right here that's right
my leg
[Music]
okay let's go time to sadness messes up
right and the dude is coming out - yeah
he clothes now I'm going to use that
black hole for me everything is just say
he's coming close to me I'm out of the
way and into it so messed up he's coming
out without all the way and then to it
it's still be me ankle in front of the
hip just like
[Music]
and that on the bow over in if she has a
beef rib which a lot of you do because
they start falling here come up grab the
arm you see but it does the same thing
in around
[Music]
yeah and your mushy yeah I asked
underneath it you see I'm right here oh
oh but watch what happens when I move my
feet together and now not in it you see
that so I move off the line of attack
like and you should feel a push
okay so on this line of attack change I
wish to one side of it you see so yeah I
wasn't able to keep it but I'm still the
one side of it you see maybe I won't be
there now right in the middle okay
that's where this one comes in
don't do it from the other side that's
where you guys forced it a lot in GUI
okay so his tag comes more to me DC so
stepping off stepping to the other foot
I'm still wanted I have to 10.com the
other way this way so you've been also
initiated apart so I can baby's head go
that way
you see how I brought it to the line of
attack and then we're coming out but
here let's work on that we can't take
you that advantage okay so he's coming
right at me so I move out of the way
okay the second Corrections do not let
him stand up what you just saw the throw
so I don't go like this and he turns
around this is the fight starting over
he's going to sweep here as much as I do
use the torque that you generate right
here right in that scapula and this
movement
[Applause]
save a everybody's movement he's right
here
oops feel the torque coming through that
chicken wing
[Music]
you have formed corruptions you're like
I gotta make them to the back bridge I
don't need to make
or at a minimum keep his head off from
that so all all I'm doing is this
initial torch that's it in default how
we balls because when you guys go for
the back race law you start turning the
true Moxie Papa just create the tour
because douchey angles already happening
right here disease center so the very
first thing I showed you is you're going
to shoulder over the head and the foot
right remember okay so now you're just
immersing it I'm taking this shoulder
and passing it under the other shoulder
you see that and that's all like you
it'll have that back what you're all
moving it will have the effect for you
guys to try it again let's just look at
okay so he's gonna do that technique
whoa I turn in Dennis he goes he brings
me all the way back up right
is this not still available once you
have the guy's balance you never give it
back you don't give it back so what the
clue I gave you was that this shoulder
when I do that is going under that foot
okay well you guys mad at this when you
add that that's how it's nice so pay
attention
I don't move anything he shook his hand
underneath so this arm stays on that
initial angle right there do you see
that I groove out of the way pass the
head don't pick the arm up that's where
you give him back his face try
but I don't let my beauty control the
situation okay so I'm here you see she's
already full but ask her oh here we go
she's trying to begin
[Music]
get any sauce so you train
watch my saw
Center
volley watch also it's not as violent as
you think it I do that slide again
that's the problem
I hold it relax but it block your Center
you're gonna curl this when you fall Oh